跟他們想像中的巨人比較不一樣一點
與孩子們暖心互動毫無違和
還大方捐出百萬版稅
就是為了改善弱勢孩童成長環境
身高190公分的這位
就是台股交易傳奇巨人節
這也是他在螢光幕前首度露面
其實我原本這次也打算不露臉
但是出版社就蠻極力的說服我
他說如果這樣的話
可以拋磚以於更多人去做善事
那大家共襄盛举
捐帮助这些弱势的小朋友
我觉得是很值得的一件事情
个性低调务实的他
从未接受过采访
不过却因为一包饼干扭转人生
如今31岁的巨人杰
在17岁那年投入投资市场
第一档投资标的就是友达
透过不断自学和上课
以及每日省下来的零用钱
用来频繁交易累积经验
甚至在念研究所时
就已經是券商VIP
畢業後也篤定選擇股市交易員從期止到當中期貨不斷學习检讨成了日后交易养分你看错行情你停损那这件事情也叫做成功
因为我曾经砍过几千万
少赔了很多钱
那对我来说这就是正确的事情
那正确的事情我就会重复做这样
三年前的航运股热潮中
也让巨人节一阵成名
投资14年时间
如今巨人节的年交易量
已经来到了5000亿元
他也强调投资不要怕赔钱
就怕没有停损概念
投资理财我是觉得没有捷径
就是第一件事情
现在的网路上其实资讯蛮多的
广泛的阅读广泛的学习
那我觉得投资是没有一夜支付这件事情
再次提醒新手小白赚钱没有捷径
广泛吸收知识依旧是巨人节每日公事
17岁靠着1万元本金翻转生命
散户巨人的传奇人生
未婉待续
巴黎雄王妮正如龍 採訪報導